thanks ted don't run away from your
problems rum to them instead we are
celebrating national rum day and i'm
joined by frankie bish from koloa rung
hello how are you thank you yeah i'm
doing great you brought us the goods for
national rum day first of all is this
like your super bowl
yeah if it was hawaiian national
hawaiian rum day then it would
definitely be a super bowl but this is a
big one for us well tell us a little bit
about this rum and then you're going to
show us how to make a cocktail but there
seems to be several varieties of cola
rum yeah we made quite a few but uh we
are made from
uh cane sugar and hawaiian mountain
rainwater filtered wine mountain
rainwater on the island of kauai we've
been making rum there for nine years
we make artisanal rums
we make many different flavors white rum
gold rum dark rum coconut all sorts of
different flavors coffee which is very
popular right now oh i like that and you
actually you made a couple of cocktails
here for us and then you're going to
show us how to make one in case people
are watching and they like to
participate national rum day themselves
everybody should what do we have here
today we have our kawaii skinny
pina colada so this is our
go ahead and give this a sip this is a
fantastic cocktail and i'll tell you
what it is
um so this is our coconut rum wow that's
refreshing one uh one and a half ounce
of our coconut rum uh quarter ounce of
our cacao rums our chocolate rum oh
there's like double ramen yeah just a
little tiny bit just for flavor uh some
coconut water
a little bit of pineapple juice and a
little bit of soda water for
effervescence but it helps keeps the
calories down yeah which everybody loves
but still get that flavor do you still
feel like you're on the islands oh man
that was good i'm saving this one for
later for sure okay and now this one
we're going to make this one together
this is beautiful what is this this is
our uh kaloa coconut uh
what am i trying to say the uh kaloa
coconut
coconut uh
we could just make it we're gonna drink
it yeah
is it a coconut decoration that's right
okay it looks like a daiquiri to me yes
coconut rum daiquiri okay so what you
got here we're gonna
put some ice in the tin
you got the specialized too like the
crust yeah the crushed ice yeah the best
okay then we're going to do two ounces
of coconut rum
i really like this coconut rum yeah it's
so good oh my god it's not too sweet no
we don't over sweeten it it's 100
natural and uh it's 40 alcohol so a
little bit more than other coconut rums
but uh the flavor is amazing um so yeah
after the two ounces of
of coconut rum we do about three
quarters ounce of lime okay
and then i do for a little bit of
sweetener i do three quarters ounce of
cocoa real coconut
what is that i've never heard of that
it's like a coconut puree coconut milk
puree but it's sweetened very tasty and
then we do add a little bit of
splash of soda water in there as well
shake it up shake it up i love the shake
now where can people buy coral rum you
can get kalo rum at total wine
you can get it at lee's liquor and a
handful of other local retailers as well
um
we're available in 32 states and in
a handful of countries too like canada
japan
i really like that coconut rum that one
is something else okay
the coconut daiquiri cola coconut
decorations all right let's try this one
which is better
oh my gosh they're both so good are you
kidding me i love it you want to get
yours total wine uh lee's liquor yeah
happy national run yeah happy national
wednesday cheers to you oh cheers to you
all right and cheers to you we're going
to send it over to rocky she stopped by
opening day of las vegas first trendy's
donuts
you see that i